tell people how you started the company
they don't may know the story well the
quick and dirty I was a Navy SEAL for
about fourteen years and on on a mission
because we deployed a lot and you know
all Special Ops guys need to stay at
sort of the pro level of training with
no place to Train when you deploy and I
was on such a deployment looking for a
way to come up with a way to keep my
guys and myself in shape for a mission
and I turned out to come up with a strap
system that used your own body weight
gravity and balance to create a complete
functional training system that you
brought the original straps with you I
mean these are going to end up I guess
in like but the TRX museum someday right
a man from from your lips to fortunes
ears all right well this fortune has
been pretty good to you right
how what give us an idea from those
straps
what kind of business have you built
well it is funny because there's a
simple system and it was an accident
and an invention and necessity who knew
you know 10 12 years after I came up
with this idea that we'd be tapping on
the door of 60 million bucks a year 60
million dollars in sales a year that's
that's that's what we'll be shooting for
this year I think we'll get to or
through it now one of the areas that
you've been focused on is the electronic
connection the technology connection
describe what you're doing well we we
figured out pretty early because no one
knew how to use straps right we figured
out that education and content both to
the end-user and then to our first line
of customers which is the training pro
of every different stripe so in physical
therapists chiropractors strengthen
conditioning coaches personal trainers
the key was educating the user on how to
use the thing so we became a Content
company and then with the rise of
digital technology we invested pretty
heavily to be on the forefront of
delivering digital technology to the
end-user no matter who you are where you
are got some celebrities I know that
like to use this though you know we've
we've had great good luck in this
business and yeah I mean everyone from
you know I mean one of our one of
Jennifer Lopez Michael Phelps that's not
so bad not so bad and you get guys like
Drew Brees out there who really become
you know aggressive advocates and it
just
way it taken off on its own